KAZ SATO: Can I start?
OK, thank you.
Thank you so much for taking
your time for my session.
What is ML Ops?
The best practices
for DevOps for ML.
I'm Kaz.
I'm a developer advocate.
So it's like an evangelist
for developers and engineers.
I'm focusing on data
analytics products,
and like TensorFlow machine
learning engine and BigQuery.
I have been working at
Google for about seven years.
And what is ML Ops?
Actually, I and my colleague
have created this word.
There is no ML Ops
word ever in Ops.
So that stands for
the DevOps for ML.
And I have been collecting
this concept or topics
of the operating production
machine learning systems
for a couple of years because
I have been keep hearing
from the ML experts
that launching is easy,
but the operating is hard--
from customers and
internal ML experts.
There's one ML
expert in Google who
has been supporting one
of the largest ML service
inside Google for many years.
And he said launching the first
version of ML system is easy,
but operating it for many
years is the hardest part.
So I thought maybe the
practices for DevOps
could work well for building
production quality ML systems.
I copied this definition
of DevOps from Wikipedia.
It says it's all about unifying
your Dev part and Ops part,
and strongly advocate
automation and monitoring
for all steps for the systems.
So you can replace that part,
IT part or system part with ML.
So to build the production
quality ML systems,
it's important to unify the
ML development and operations,
and advocate automation and
monitoring of ML systems.
And we have been publishing a
couple of papers in the past,
such as the ML, "Machine
Learning, the High-Interest
Credit Card of Technical Debt."
I call it as an "ML
Technical Debt" paper.
That was written by an
ML expert inside Google
who has been operating
the large scale
machine learning production
system for many years.
And they have
learned many things
in the past over 10, 15
years, and they have written
the best practice as a paper.
Another important paper is the
"Rules of Machine Learning,"
or "Rules of ML" paper.
And with those papers added
with the other many episodes
I have collected with the
customers and customer
engineers, I'm collecting many
anti-patterns and solutions
for the production
machine learning systems.
And I have three
agendas for today.
One is the anti-patterns
for development time,
patterns for the deployment,
and operation anti-patterns.
So let's start with the
development anti-patterns.
The first pattern
is the ML superhero.
Maybe you have seen
him in your company.
He's a superhero because he's
a researcher who understands
everything, like a
mathematical model, what's
happening inside his model.
But he also has a skill set
to built his own batch Spark
cluster by himself,
to do everything
from preparation,
data prep preparation,
or the transformation training.
And also, he has a
skill set, and build
and operating the infrastructure
by using Kubernetes,
writing the Docker
file by himself.
And also, he can be
a product manager
who can write the
design dock by himself.
And also, he is a very
fluent in communicating
with the stakeholders,
like CXOs and executives.
And he does it from the
proof of concept phase
to the production phase.
He's a Superman.
But he doesn't scale.
So your first project would
be awesome for depending
on that kind of hero.
But if an enterprise
or startup wants
to reproduce the same
success with ML systems
with many different features
or products or divisions,
then you have to hire that kind
of superhero, tens of them.
So instead, you have to
build a scalable team
by splitting your roles
into much simpler roles.
So you can have multiple roles,
such as the ML researcher
or data engineer, infrastructure
engineer, product manager,
and business decision-maker.
Now, let me show one
example of the team.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
KAZ SATO: So that was
the demonstration,
we had built for the
I/O Next last year.
So some of you may have
seen this last year.
And this was a demonstration,
but for us, it's
a production machine
learning system.
And I designed it.
I had written a rough design
doc for this by myself.
And worked with the vendor
called BrainPad in Japan
who has expertise on building
the production machine learning
system for many years.
So because I wanted to
make a production quality
demonstration, so I asked
them to build a team for this
because the I/O is
not only the one
venue for these demonstrations.
We had to present
this demonstration
at many large events, like
Next San Francisco, Next Tokyo,
and India, and
many other places.
So we cannot rely
on the ML superhero.
So BrainPad had created a
team with a researcher who
will build the Word2Vec
model running on TensorFlow
for the candy recommendation,
and also the image recognition
and [INAUDIBLE] while running.
And also a software engineer
who uses the ML APIs, speech
to text API and inner API.
Hardware engineer
who focuses on how
to control the robot precisely.
And project manager
who leads the team.
And I was the business
decision-maker,
communicating with all the other
stakeholders, like marketing,
PR team, and legal, everything.
So that went well
because BrainPad
has practice to
create very tightly
coupled teams with the
researchers and engineers
as one team.
But sometimes you have
this problem, a black box
that nobody understands.
If you create a
machine learning team
with the researchers and
engineers and info engineers,
it's possible that nobody
understand the whole system.
Because researchers would
create the first prototype
with his or her
Jupyter Notebook.
And then engineer
takes that code,
does the refactoring on that
to bring it to production.
And then researchers
would not follow
what's happening in
the production code.
At the same time,
maybe engineer don't
match knowledge about
what's happening inside
the model itself.
Then nobody understands
what's happening
inside the whole
system, and it's
really hard for the
optimization as a whole system.
So the "ML Technical
Debt" paper says
at Google, a hybrid
research approach where
engineers and researchers
are embedded together
on the same team,
that has helped
reduce this source of
friction significantly.
So not only building
a scalable team,
but also, it's really
important to have tight,
close communication
between the researcher
and engineer to
understand everything,
and share all the same
results, like a code and model.
And, for example,
maybe engineer can
help introduce a new scalable
platform, like Cloud ML Engine,
working with the researchers.
You can do that because we
have introduced a new feature,
scikit-learn and XGBoost
spot on the Cloud ML Engine,
not only in TensorFlow.
So, for example,
researchers can start
using the scikit-learn
on Jupyter Notebook
to define their model.
And then, engineer work
together to port it
to the Cloud ML Engine.
So let me show some
video that is created
by Steve Greenberg,
my colleague, how
you can use the scikit-learn
on machine learning engine.
So for the first part,
maybe the researchers
can get started with
Jupyter Notebook
to find the usual
scikit-learn model.
So you can use the BigQuery
for getting the training
data from database.
And you can use the
ordinary API on scikit-learn
to do the pre-processing or
splitting data, everything.
Yeah, here it is splitting
the data to the training data
and test data.
And you can also use the
pipeline API of scikit-learn
to build the pipeline
for training.
And then call the fit
function to train the model,
and try the prediction
and get the result.
So this is the
part of researchers
can do with the usual practice.
And this is where you can get
the help from the ML engineer
or your infra engineer.
This is where you are copying
the scikit-learn model
to the Google Cloud
[INAUDIBLE] so
that the ML engine can read it.
And also, you can
use ML engine command
to define a new version with
that scikit-learn model running
on ML engine.
Like this.
And finally, you can try
learning it with ML engine.
So it is trying to
try the prediction
with the scikit-learn
model running on the cloud.
And you can get
here same accuracy.
An important point here is
that, by using the ML engine
as the prediction
serving infrastructure
for your scikit-learn
model, you don't
have to think much about the
scalability and variability
by yourself.
Usually there's a huge
gap between the POC
model, POC systems, and
the production systems.
You have to think
about how to build
your cluster with the
Kubernetes and containers,
and you have to think about
the lifecycle of each instance
and containers.
But by using ML engine,
it's much easier.
And engineers can help that,
working with the researchers
to bring the POC
code into production.
So, next slide.
Next pattern is CACE, or Change
Anything, Changes Everything.
It's a very unique
characteristic
or the behavior of ML systems.
It's an entanglement you
can find in ML systems.
That means a single change,
one change to one feature,
could affect all of
the other features.
Or single changes in
the hyper-parameters
or any way you prepare your
training data or feature,
that could change the
behavior of everything,
like how you can do your
regularization or running rate
or sampling or thresholds.
That could change the
behavior of the whole system.
That's the reason why the ML
experts said launching is easy,
but operating is hard.
"Rules of ML" paper
defines Rule 14,
starting with an interpretable
model makes debugging easier.
And there's another
rule, it's Rule 40.
Keep ensembles simple.
What is a simple model?
The deep learning
model is so attractive,
and you can say to
the business people
that we are using deep
learning with an AI system.
But sometimes the deep
model makes things complex.
So if you want to use deep model
in your production systems,
you can use that judiciously
because linear model is much,
much easier for debugging.
It's much easier
to train the model
and get the global
optimum, whereas if you're
using the deep model, usually
the model is non-complex.
That means you are not sure
if you're getting the best
result from training or not.
You have to make many trials.
And also, it's important to
make everything interpretable
by humans, not
having a black box.
Another pattern here
or solution here
is to use ensembled models,
rather than using a huge,
one monolithic model.
So you could have
one big, deep model
that takes hundreds of the
features from the system.
Then it's really hard to debug
or troubleshoot against that.
So one practice you can use is
to have a smaller model, small
and simpler model.
Works just like a parts
factory or automobile factory.
And you could have
another model that
assembles all the synthesized
features from those factories.
So it works as an
assembly plant.
And it's also important to
have everything semantically
interpretable model so that the
persons for troubleshooting,
like operators, can
easily find what
will be the problem, what will
be the cause of the problem.
Is it this model, this
model, or this model?
Rather than having
a gigantic, one
monolithic model where the
trouble would be embedded
somewhere in the model.
I wanted to show
one demonstration.
It's Konpeki.
It's an image classifier for
the use case built by Aucnet.
Aucnet is the largest
provider for the real time
auction for use case in Japan.
And they handle over 5
million auctions per year.
And they have built a TensorFlow
based image classifier
specialized for the use case.
So the users can upload all
the different pictures of a car
from different angles, like from
front and back or side or tires
or steering wheels.
And then systems classify
that, and you can get your car
make and model name and
classification of these images
at high accuracy.
They have built it.
And it has been on production
for over two years.
And one thing they did when they
were building the production
system was to split the model.
So Aucnet initially created one
big deep learning model that
takes all the features into it.
But it ended up always splitting
the model into smaller models.
So they found they
were able to do
better troubleshooting
or better optimization
with the whole system.
Ah, sorry about that.
Why is that?
SPEAKER 1: It's back.
KAZ SATO: Mmm.
Does it work?
Ah, sorry.
OK.
Let me try it.
So it's much easier for
the production systems
in troubleshooting.
So that was the pattern you can
see in your development phase.
And let's take a look at the
deployment anti-patterns.
The first pattern is lack
of ML lifecycle management.
The one scenario could
be, maybe a researcher
would just start writing
the POC with Notebook.
And he or she does
everything on it from POC
to production, like
data preparation,
transformation, training,
validation, and serving,
and deploying.
And researcher got high accuracy
on the production service.
But he or she would
forget about the system
after one or two years.
So after one year or two
years, maybe somebody
found the accuracy
dropping slowly.
And director of the
business asks the researcher
to update the model
ASAP, like by tomorrow.
The researcher will somehow
finds the old Notebook
on laptop, tries to remember
how to go through, quickly,
all these cells, and do
every process manually.
And wonders, why am I doing
the emergency plumbing?
He or she is a researcher,
and this is not his job.
So the solution is to think
about ML life cycle management.
So integrated job
management, job
orchestration so that you
can define all the components
as a part of the whole
job of orchestration,
starting from the data
ingestion, analysis,
and validation, training,
and serving, and logging,
and monitoring.
Not as the ad hoc script
running on the Jupyter Notebook.
You have to build everything
as a continuous deployment
on repeatable infrastructure,
not depending on the researcher
only.
One example of building that
kind of workflow is using Argo.
Argo is an open-source tool for
workflow as a workflow engine
for Kubernetes containers.
So you can use this
tool to build this kind
of orchestration for ML system.
And actually, we have tried
that for the one demonstration
called AI in Motion.
This is a demonstration you
can find in the showcase
area in the Moscone South where
we have the robot balls rolling
on the table.
And we have a smartphone,
Pixel 2, up above
that takes all the
images of the robot
balls, and running
the object detection
model of the
TensorFlow, and control
the robots by using SDK.
And this object detection
model was trained at the cloud
by using ML engine.
And it also uses
Reinforcement Learning, RL,
to control the balls.
So if you're interested,
you can play by yourself
by going to the showcase.
And we had to build the
ML pipeline or ML workflow
because, as you can
see, it's very important
to have high accuracy
on object detection
at every different venue.
So each venue would have a
different lighting environment,
like white lighting or
color lighting, or strengths
of the lighting
would be different.
So it's important to be
able to retrain the model
and to get the best
result at each venue.
So as long as you're
using the Jupyter Notebook
and run using the
manual process,
it's not scalable and
portable as a demonstration.
So for this demonstration,
we have built the ML pipeline
by using Argo.
So starting from loading the
training data and training
and evaluation, and
also, in this case,
we have built a pipeline
for converting everything
into a TensorFlow like model.
Converting the TensorFlow
like model and deploy
the TensorFlow, write files
for the mobile devices.
And let me show some examples.
This is the working
Argo user interface
for the AI in Motion
demonstrations.
And the UI works
just like the UI
you have in your
cloud data flow.
So if you click one
of the workflows,
you can see what's the current
status of the workflow.
Like what's the status?
Has it succeeded
or has it failed?
Or starting time, end
time, and duration.
Just like the things you can
see on the cloud data flow.
So by having this kind
of orchestration tool,
then you don't have to go
through all the Jupyter
Notebook processes
by yourself manually.
Instead, you can have someone,
like operators or engineers
or the researchers, pressing
the buttons of the workflow,
the Argo, to go through all
the repeatable processes
between the model,
and deploy it.
Another pattern you can
see in the deployment time
is a lack of data validation.
In the usual,
ordinary IT system,
the behavior of the system
is defined by the program
code you have written.
So you have to write a
unit test to validate
the behavior of your system.
But what about the
machine learning system?
Because you are not writing
the code for defining
the behavior of your system.
Instead, your system would
be using training data
to define the behavior
of the system.
And how do you validate that?
The solution could be the
data validation tools.
And one option is the TFX,
or TensorFlow Extended.
That is an open-source
tool provided
by the TensorFlow
team that provides
multiple different useful
tools for the ML Ops practices,
such as the transformation
for the data,
or the model analysis that
I'll be talking about later,
or the serving.
And one of those features
is data validation.
At this point, we
haven't open-sourced
the data validation
part of yet, but we
hope to have it soon
in the near future.
By using TFX for
data validation,
you can easily define
the configuration file
for the data validation,
such as the type and domain
for each feature or
input data, whether it's
a string or integer or
what kind of range it has.
It presents instances of
each of values or variancy
or distribution by comparing the
divergence between two values.
And if it fits into a certain
threshold, then it's OK.
Otherwise, you have to
check whether your training
data is OK or not.
And "TFX" paper
says we want to user
to treat data errors
with the same rigor
and care that deal
with debugs in code.
Because the data is your
code in your ML system.
Actually, the Google Play team
has introduced the practice
of data validation
so that they were
able to increase the install
rate for applications for 2%.
So lastly, I'd like to
discuss about anti-patterns
you can find in operation time.
Ah, sorry about that.
SPEAKER 2: It's OK.
KAZ SATO: Why is that?
Is it working?
OK.
Now updating.
Maybe, yeah, we
try connecting to--
SPEAKER 2: It's
working properly.
KAZ SATO: Is it working?
SPEAKER 1: I think it is.
KAZ SATO: But it looks
like it's not my laptop.
Looks like they switched.
Yeah, I can continue
with the other laptop.
And can I use your clicker?
Where's clicker?
Oh yeah, I have it.
Not working.
It's slow.
It's slow, but working.
Sorry about that.
So lack of continuous
monitoring.
So any kind of model
would see the drop
of the accuracy over time.
Maybe it would take
years, or maybe
quarters or months or hours,
but the accuracy would drop.
And if there's no
practice for your team
for continuous monitoring
on your accuracy
or behavior of your
model, the first person
who'd notice the
drop of the accuracy
would be the end
user or consumers.
They would be frustrated with
the performance or experience,
and business team
would notice that.
And director asked you to
update the model ASAP again.
So that's what we want to avoid.
This is another pattern,
training-serving skew.
That means any
single differences,
like differences of the training
data or pre-processing method
or the windows you specify,
between training and serving
or POC to production,
that changes the accuracy.
Another pattern is not knowing
the freshness requirements.
So each ML system would have
its own freshness requirement.
For example, if you want to
build the news aggregation
website, then you may want
to update your ML model
every five minutes to
get the latest updates.
E-commerce site
item recommendation
can wait for a couple
of days or a week
until updating the models.
The natural language processing
for customer satisfaction
measurement may use the same
model for a couple of months,
or may be longer than that.
Voice recognition doesn't
require any updates
on the model.
Object detection
sometimes requires
retraining the model for every
setup, as I mentioned in the AI
in Motion case.
And "Rules of ML" paper
says, Rule Number 9,
detect problems before
exporting models.
Then Rule Number 8, know
the freshness requirements
for your system.
And the solution could be
a TFMA, or TensorFlow Model
Analysis.
That is a new feature
included in TensorFlow
to do analytics on your model.
And by using TFMA,
you can follow
some practices or
rules, such as Rule 24,
measure the delta
between your models.
Rather than watching the single
accuracy of the current model,
you have to see the
changes or trend
between the different the
models in a time series.
How the accuracy
will be trending?
Is it increasing or
is it decreasing?
And another practice
you can use with TFMA
is using the sliced metrics
for better model analysis.
Not only using a single
ROC or AUC number,
you can use different
types of features,
or different windows
of the features,
to get deeper insight of
the behavior of your model.
Let me show some
example of using TFMA.
This is the step where you're
importing the TFMA library
and define the slices
by using the API of TFMA
by using the Jupyter Notebook.
And by defining the
slices, in this case,
the code is using
Chicago taxi trip data
for training a model
for predicting the taxi
fares in each trip.
And the easiest way is
to get your single ROC
car or the accuracy
on the whole model.
But by defining on
different slices,
like sliced by the hour in the
day, or day in a week or year,
you can understand
much more details
about the behavior
of your model.
Now it defines the
slices so that you
can get multiple
accuracies for each slice.
In this case, it's
a time series.
So you can see different
activities provided
for each slice, hour in a day.
And this highest accuracy
is achieved at noon time
where you would have
many, many taxi uses.
And once you have confirmed that
your model works as intended
and there's no problem on
the accuracy or behavior,
then you can use the
versioning of the models
on machine learning engine.
The machine learning engine
provides some APIs and CLI
to register multiple
versions of your model,
and choose which
one of the models
you want to use as
a default. So you
can use those CLIs,
command lines, or the APIs
to define models and use
it as a default model.
Another rule.
The "Rules of ML" paper says
the second rule is to first
design and implement metrics.
So if you want to
capture any problems
or want to capture any good
things or good feedback
from customers, define
metrics to capture
all of those behavior
from your ML model.
For example, Google+ team has
been collecting many metrics
from the behavior
user activities,
such as how many
expands per read,
or how many reshares per read,
or how many +1s or comments per
read.
So all of those,
these small metrics,
can be a good feature for
defining the goodness of post.
So that was the final
practice and patterns.
So, summary.
Development anti-patterns.
You cannot rely on a
single ML superhero.
Rather than that, you have
to build a scalable team.
And at the same time, you
cannot build a ML black box.
And you have to be aware
that ML systems can
have this CACE, or Change
Anything, Change Everything
behavior.
For deployment, it's
really important
to think about the machine
learning lifecycle management
by using the tools such as
Argo or the Cloud Composer.
And also, you have to understand
the behavior of the ML system
is defined by training
data and your model.
Lastly, it's very important
to keep monitoring and logging
your systems.
So it's very important to set
up your monitoring tool set
and define the
refreshment requirement
for your machine
learning use cases
by using the tools like TFMA.
And if you are interested
in those practices,
please take picture
of these links' names
so you can learn more
about those practices
with those papers.
The "ML Technical Debt"
papers, "Rules of ML"
papers, "TFX,"
and "TFMA" papers.
And I'd like to
give special thanks
to Amy Unruh, who's the
colleague of my DA team
who's built this TFMA demo.
Norihiro Shimoda collected
all the customer episodes.
And Keisuke built the Argo ML
pipeline for the demonstration.
So with that, thank you so much.